joining us in our Louisville's mayor
that's Craig Greenberg and the interim
chief of police Jacqueline Gwen
villaroel good morning to you both we
say good morning because it's a polite
thing to say but there's nothing good
about this morning please know the world
is mourning with you both this morning
and mayor I want to start with you we
just heard in the tag about the officer
how he's doing but I know that you
visited him yesterday what can you tell
us about what you saw is he able to
communicate
I met with the other officers who were
injured as a result of yesterday's
shooting and I met with officer wilt's
family yesterday as did the chief and
the governor yesterday after this tragic
event and we fortunately got some good
news last night he still officer Wilt is
still in critical condition but he did
make some positive progress throughout
the day and so we were praying for his
continued recovery as we mourn the news
of a fifth victim that we received late
last night another victim passed as a
result of yesterday's evil active gun
violence Chief what can you tell us
about when you first heard the news that
this had happened in your city what was
your first thought
foreign
and I was like this cannot be happening
the evil incident that took place on
yesterday should never have been played
out but I just have to say that the
heroism of my officers on yesterday who
responded in three minutes to encounter
and engage the suspect and to stop the
threat from him actually taking
additional lives should truly be
recognized and so they're unwavering
stats in a position to make sure that
lives were continue to be preserved and
and now we're just hopeful that the
officer that actually got shot yesterday
that he is able to pull through but the
loss of life yesterday was tragic and a
sad day for our city
mayor I know like the governor you lost
a friend yesterday in the shooting you
two have been a targeted person to gun
violent so you're no stranger to this it
has affected you personally and one of
your campaign themes was you were going
to do something about this we were going
to stop this what are you thinking today
what can we realistically do because I
like everybody else I'm so tired of
starting the morning news with these
type of stories what can we really do
here
hey yeah you and me both Gail I think so
many people across our city across our
country want action and so we are going
to do everything we can from a local
level we have started by changing the
way that we return confiscated illegal
guns to the state by removing the firing
pins before turning them over as we're
required to do under state law we're
working with lmpd to reduce the amount
of illegal guns on our street we're
investing in people and neighborhoods
and the root causes of crime and poverty
so that kids grow up with the ability to
pursue their own hopes and dreams but we
have to do more we must call on our
state legislatures to give cities like
Louisville the autonomy to control our
own destiny with respect to reducing
this gun violence epidemic we need help
from Congress to pass legislation that
can give us more tools and ability to
try to prevent
it's like yesterday from never happening
again in Louisville in Nashville or any
city in America so your message today
guys from both of you to your your
community this morning as well
messages we need to come together
we need to come together with support
and love and prayer for those who are
still recovering
for those who are grieving and then also
we need to come together to take action
as we were just talking about Gail
if you care about other loved ones in
your city and your country if you care
about officers like officer Wilt who ran
into this situation
faced by somebody who was have holding
an AR
-15 waiting for your arrival Let's Take
Action let's do something about this
let's not have other Mayors and Chiefs
of police having to be on your show
grieving about people who they've lost
in their City
yes I agree with you mayor I agree with
you that officer very brave we were all
pulling for him today I'm so sorry for
the loss of life in your city thank you
both for taking the time I know you've
got a lot to do
thank you thank you